when you see the mining businesses
themselves uh obviously the oil and gas
industry the kind of energy producers
outside of bitcoin they've become major
players in a variety of different ways
everything from down i think there's a
houston oil and gas kind of bitcoin
mining like meet-up that goes on uh in
that area all the way to we've seen
reports of some of the major energy
producers in the united states uh maybe
doing pilots i think is kind of how
they've been framed as they're kind of
testing stuff out what are you seeing
there with like the integration of what
maybe you and i would consider like
bitcoin natives people who are trying to
build these mining facilities with some
of these more kind of oil and gas or
energy native organizations
well you know it so it's interesting so
absolutely in the past couple months
we've seen a pro proliferation of uh
perhaps creativity and what sort of
energy sources and types can be applied
to mining and vice versa and so it's not
just oil and gas or and it's not just
you know standard sort of um known
sustainable sources like wind and solar
but we're seeing everything from um you
know like compost materials
to you know um like tires and you know
all sorts of um materials that can be
used to extract energy from
and folks are are you know looking at
the um looking at the uh modeling the
scenarios to see if money can be made
there and of course
um when there's free energy there's an
ability to monetize that with mining and
so
folks on the energy side are i think
getting really smart they've gone up the
learning curve with bitcoin they know
that they can supplement
and add a revenue stream to what they've
already built by introducing mining
which can of course as you know be done
intermittently and so it's a great match
for lots of different um
modes of energy and i think that you
know people are making um a variety of
experiments right now and so i imagine
in 18 months time we'll have a lot more
information but it's really fun to see
the creativity um you know
entrepreneurial thinking that's
happening in the space including from
folks on the energy side that probably
have neither thought of themselves as
entrepreneurial or as
bitcoin native folks but bitcoin of
course is energy-backed money and so if
you're in energy you are um you know
soon to be if not already in bitcoin
and we're seeing that realization happen